i'm here talking this afternoon to
benoit felton benoit you're going to be
talking here at the ftth council about
some market research you just completed
in portugal and france but previously
you did some in sweden before we start
talking about the new stuff just
reminders of the findings you had from
that report in sweden so what we were
trying to achieve
was to basically measure attitudes
and satisfaction
for broadband users
and then look at whether
fiber made a difference in these
attitudes and
satisfaction what we saw in sweden
essentially is that first of all fibre
users are very satisfied with their
broadband much more so than dsl users
but also that dsl users like fibre users
perceive fiber as a better platform
and finally that there is a significant
difference in behavior
both the time spent online and the type
of things that are done online are
different and more advanced for fiber
users
okay and what about uh what about this
new research so what we wanted to
achieve with the france and portugal
surveys was put this in perspective of
market maturity sweden is a very mature
market fiber has been around for a long
time
portugal is a relatively mature market
but it's not been around for that long
and france is a fairly new market to
fiber
and
what we saw
was that typically
the perception of fiber by dsl users
is not as good in portugal as it is in
sweden and it's even worse in france why
because fiber hasn't been around for a
long time and therefore dsl users have
never heard of people who have fiber or
experience fiber so they think it's just
as good as what they've currently got or
just as bad depending on how you want to
frame it
and
so essentially we see that maturity does
have a significant impact the other
thing which was quite interesting
is that
the behavior of dsl and fiber users in
france and portugal is not that
different
our assumption is that
the time that they've had the new
platform is not long enough for them to
have explored its possibilities whereas
in sweden they've had fiber on average
for three or four years and so they have
explored those possibilities and they
use it more and for more advanced things
so going forward is it all about fiber
well
quite clearly what this analysis
demonstrates is that fiber does make a
difference for end users but it also
highlights the key challenge for
operators deploying fiber which is
how do you convince
someone who's never used it that the
experience is different and radically
better and
what we see is that part of it is market
maturity in other words the longer fiber
has been available on the market the
more people are aware that it is a
better platform
of course you can accelerate that
through marketing campaigns and finding
clever ways to get people to experience
it without necessarily owning it but
there is an element of this which will
be solved by time
okay
just before you go one thing i'm really
interested in is the sheer scale of the
work that is involved in producing these
surveys i mean how do you go about
finding this data
well the the it is challenging and and
it's
uh it's even more challenging because
we're doing this in numerous countries
uh but i have to say that the internet
has been a ruin to market researchers
because what we used to have to do over
the phone
and took a lot of time and manpower to
do we can now do over the internet where
basically
people will fill in surveys
and we will then analyze those forms
it's still a pretty big task but
actually the biggest challenge is not so
much in
gathering the data the biggest challenge
is in building
a questionnaire that will not skew the
results
and also that will deliver
the insights that you want rather than
something that you're not sure you can
use a lot of market studies
unfortunately suffer from poor wording
and one of the things that we did to
ensure that this didn't happen was we
hired an expert in
questionnaire buildup
to make sure that we weren't skewing the
data in any way
and i'm very proud of the results that
we've got and i invite everyone to uh
have a look at them either here at the
conference or through the series of
webinars that we're going to do
afterwards with the council
benoit thanks very much for talking to
us you're welcome
so some interesting new research soon to
be available on portugal and france